tee
teemetee
poooo ん
大口径と言います
思った以上にたくさんの方がいて
ほんとと思っ
ね
越冬皆さん僕フラン建築家というのを活動
させていただいています全地区かっていう
とどんなイメージを持ちいいですかね
えっ僕はきゅん日には
だいたい一行にこうプレゼンに行ったり
するともっと良いかついい人が来ると思っ
てたと言われて
今を誰も非常勤
学生に教えているんですけど絶対にも勝手
になって詰んじゃって
顎に間違われるっていう
ちょっと今悩みのターン
まずは誰か建築家として普段どんなことを
やっているか現地化でどんなものかという
のを1を説明
立ちにくくなっている
えっと
まあ今
まずは皆さん住宅を設定するっていう
イメージがあるかなと思うけど今住宅結構
過剰にも
供給されていて余っている状態ですね
今の主なテーマは住宅の増改築であったり
イノベーションであったりあとは
マンションのリノベーションですねそう
いったものをやっている建築家が多い
まあその一方で住宅以外にも小さな
ギャラリーを高設定
向かって右側の写真はえっと今表参道に
設定中のやはり商業建築みたいなものを
設定したりとかっ競ったことも言ってい
ます
一方でへと展覧会の会場構成
あって左側はあの
後席のデザイナーさんの個展を
小さな部屋で
そういったこともた付
えっとこれはですねまちづくり
ワークショップという
参加させていただいてまして
学生さんがメンバーとなった
ワークショップを繰り返しながら
砂浜でインスタレーション提案をしたりだ
とか
あとは
向かって左下のは
照明の&んですね行灯をデザインしたりと
かあとは学生さんと町の人たちみんなで
言い合いはいで
街がさの無人駅の改修をしたことかそう
いった
健康地域と一体化
発動も下にしています
あとはまあまだ若手なもので越冬
公共建築のコンペに参加していたとかあと
は展覧会に自分からっていうか出店したり
とかあとはあの著名な先生と一緒に
都市計画
恐竜共同で参加したりとかそういったこと
をしてい
一般的なそんな活動しているんですが今日
はもうちょっと規模が大きめの
プロジェクト2つちょっとご紹介したいな
と思う
同規模がちょっと大きいもので
の店舗型の手にもご余るような
プロジェクトなんですけどちょっと皆さん
にも起きていただいて一緒に
こんなプロジェクターんだってことを考え
いただけたらなと思う持っています
えっ一つ目です
これはちょっと変わった水族館の提案でし
て
皆さんご存知の通り
地球照美が7ばいい
だいたいに苦情のことしか人間は考えて
ないんですけど一度その海の中に入って
しまうと
陸上の常識が通用しないような世界が
この地貴女に7割存在しているというのは
すごい面白い
一方で人間は
の水族館というものをつくって
4次的な海の世界を陸上に
体験して非常に安全で非常に見やすい海の
世界を陸上に体験し
今回にいたこれはのガラスメーカーさんが
この会社のガラス製品を利用して何か
面白いことを考えてくれ
いうのがきっかけではじめています
僕は注目したのがこの熱田0.12 no
ブースの
マック能から数
これ実際はあの液晶テレビの表面に張られ
ていたりとか携帯のあの嫁に払っていそう
いったガラスの製品なんですけどそれを
現在として展開できないかなと思ういうの
をちょっと考えて
これを使って三と思います
ペットやったことはきわめて簡単でして
えっこの
極薄ガラスの松ガラスを直径100
メーターの森こうしてしまって
それを生み浮かべる
っていう提案を出し
そうすると何が起こるかという
いいますと
これ水中ガラスの写真なんですけど
越冬
は水面が
いろいろ波打っていると思うんですけど
そこにガラスを振っておいた時に表面が高
ちょっと硬く硬質化するんですよね
それが硬くなった瞬間に仲がすごい見
やすくなっ
それが水中ガラスの特徴なんですけど今回
もざらすなっくふって浮かべることで急に
そんな方はすごく見やすくなると
そういった
炎症が起こることを張ってきました
で実際に本当に行くのかとか
ではどうやって水族館するっていうのを
考え始めました
まずえっとガラス
幕はすごい不意のですごい軽いんですねな
ので
を浮かべると
0.25
てみます出て253
増税だけでこの
重さち中と浮力が
成立するので
もういきます
田立ちょっと注意しなきゃいけないところ
があって
端っこ
幹部ですね端部から海の水が口を入って
しまうともう海お水の重され高を沈んでて
しまうので端っこだけは何とかして水が
入らないように工夫しなきゃいけません
このグラフがですね向かって左側のグラフ
を見ていただくと何を表しているかといい
ますと
ガラスの厚みに対してどれくらいの重さの
ものが乗っかっても壊れないか
というのを表現してくださいグラフです
越冬
このガラスの厚みがこの
熱い報道を重いものがのるって事を表して
います
ガラス夏の子を薄くしていくと当然彼の
ガラスの強度はちっちゃくなる曰くなって
いるので
乗せれるものが軽くなっていくんですね
ちょっとここで面白いのを発見したという
のが今回の話でして厚みが0.5ミリって
いうの
下の合った瞬間に
より重いものを乗せられるっていうなんか
不思議な逆転現象がいい
これ構造快適のまあ構造化の人と一緒に
入っているんですけどそれで逆転現象が
起こった
いうところが朝発見できました
これどういうことかなっていうのを
ちょっと会でをわかりやすく説明しますと
ガラスがすごく薄ければ薄いほど
まあ柔らかくなるいいんでしたガラス
柔らかくなるので
重いものが乗ったときに
曲がってくる曲がり具合がすごい大きく
なるんですよ
薄ければ薄いほど大事レイクって割る前に
曲がってくれるんですけど
割る前に海の子の浮力が
買ってくれ
割る前に体重が成立してしまう
っていう構造解析の結果になりました
8これがだんだんメンズっていいんです
けど
あの
上に人はこれ人ですね
ここにあのガラスが高
今していた
へと思うここから
見ます
1ん
おいちっこい10m20メーカーを深さで
てこの辺にいるぞというのを
ただ調べて
ちょっと拡大すると
ここ0-1ですこれ
こういう感じでは
マイナー旅へ暗いんだけどは
に苦情な政策が他と違うよう
すごい
の塊を持った水族館
えあの先ほどのグラフで競ったの0.1
ミニのガラスですと56キロまで耐え
られるとってたんですけどまぁ実際歩き
たいので歩くと
越冬
56キロ
大人だ
56こうなってしまうとはれちゃう
子供が両足で
歩けないんですね大人は
王女に歩けないんで子どもしか乗れないっ
てことにちょっとなっちゃいまして
あの大人は乗れません
あと子供もすごい柔らかい
マルイ靴を入ってもらえないとちょっと
困る
これが水明子のです
こういうふうにえっと
ここに立ったときに下にその
の世界が広がっているよう
そういった処女かならないかなと
これを行う大人は寝れば
でございます
もう一つが head or
今ので一つ目です
もう一つが x 以上のカモシカ道って
言う
んですけどこれはある雑誌の企画で
オリンピックについて
ちょっと何か提案を考えてほしいと言われ
たのがきっかけで動き始めたプロジェクト
です
僕にとってオリンピックっていうのはまあ
2020年に決まったってことは
素晴らしいことだと思うんですけど今
ところから2020年以降のその後の話で
もなかなか議論
上がってないなーっていうのは
正直なところでして今回その
巨額の資本が動きますしあとは若い世代に
対して
負の遺産を残していかないようなそういっ
たオリンピックにする必要があるなんて
すごい感じるのでその辺は問題意識として
捉えて
合計案を考えさせてもらいました
えっとここがその
競技場がたくさん集まっている
映像んと言われる湾岸エリアですここを
テーマに考えています
ぼくがかんがえたことはもう簡単に言い
ますと2つです
戦後に植林して今バスタイプを迎えつつ
あるのに
なかなかその気にだして使うことができ
ない
国産の木材
を利用していかだをつくりましてその
いかだを大量に海に浮かべて
いい形の第一って思うんです
これはオリンピック期間中に市民活動の
プラットフォームになる
っていう提案が一つ
もう一つが船の後ろと呼ばれてまして
選手村を民家のデベロッパの方が
マンションを食べ
選手村作るんですけ
結局その
マンションが乱立していく風景
あと曲はあまり良くないなと思ったので
世界中の豪華客船を誘致しまして合格性を
つなげて
一番7点にを収容する選手村を作れる
だろうと
僕は付メモしろ
という名前言ってよっ
えっと
まあ現状こういう場所なんですけど
こうなりますいっビフォーアフター
てっペット北
5年
桃
この対ろいのがいかだのかいっ
ちょっと第六敷き詰めたんですか
えっ
えっとこの
向かって左側にあるのが
これで17000円周囲てきています
えっとオリンピック期間中は歩行者用の
インフラにもなって競技競技場高いろいろ
ここを歩きながらこう
ていけるような
場所になっています
を
例えばその市民の自由な活動っていうのは
水上マーケット7
あまりその
鹿に対応されない
経済活動を直する場所であったりあとは
レジャーとして回成功するところ
であったり
パブリックビューイング
お祭りのその待てるみんなで楽しめるドっ
ていう場所になればいいなと誰のものでも
ないこっちが
年できたらいいなと
これはあの今ちょっとある
ですからその協力者を得てえっと
スポンサーを走も探しながら一部でもいい
ので実現したいと思う動いているところ
えっと以上が2つプロジェクトをお見せし
たんですけど結構ストのちょっとそうだっ
たと思うんですが
えっと
最初にご紹介した
マンションとかのリノベーションとかそう
いった小さいプロジェクトであっても今回
のような大きなプロジェクトであっても僕
が常にその考えていることっていうのが
ありまして
それは
空想
現実を常に絶対行ったり来たりし
を考えてい
と言う
この時の空想というのは
まあ
本当であればかられるにその存在していた
はずの世界っていうのがあるはずだって罪
庫を創造してそこからのヒントを得る
んその風速
現実というのは
自分一人の想像力っていうのは常に付いた
限界があるのでその想像力の限界を
乗り越えるための
そして現実ての捉えて言って風葬と現実が
交代率的にあるんではなくて
相互補完的にどちらもポジティブな意味で
空想と現実がある
それを常に意識しながら
でなんでそんなことをしているかと言うと
究極的には
どうしてもこの空想と現実というと
貴方は現実
に向き合って空想なんていうのはこう
無視されていくのが一般的だと思うんです
けど
それだけだとその他の人に対する思いやり
であるとか
ここにいないんものに対する想像力である
とかそういったものが少しずつを矮小化し
ていってしまうんだろうなっていうのは今
現在社会を見て思ってました
そういったものを少しでも喚起できるよう
なまあそういった空間であったりイメージ
であったりといったものを常にてかいい
社会
提示し続けていきたいなと
以上